ricardo larrivée papara de la tablée des
chefs depuis quoi on me dit 18 ans à
ricardo bonsoir et les débuts ont soit
ricardo vous vous n'êtes pas tout seul
dans cette histoire le jeune homme et
quelques jeunes stefano faita jérôme
ferrer winter rosso car l'ennemi cannes
bâtisse pepiot mario martel éric
gonzalez
frédérique cyr c'est important parce que
la restauration a frappé aussi de plein
fouet la vous voyez votre vie votre
votre métier vous êtes très vraiment et
puis c'est important que des chefs de
partout au québec parce que dans le fond
on veut on veut redonner vraiment à tous
les organismes qui viennent en aide aux
gens seuls les gens qui sont qui ont des
problèmes de santé mentale
les centres les jeunes sont en
transition dans les centres jeunesse
c'est hyper important à la banque
alimentaire etc suivant les gens avec
qui travaille comme les moissons 800
comme nous on trouve la cuisine de celle
en barriques québec
on rappelle des cuisiniers on va faire
dans les semaines qui viennent 30000 la
de chimie végétale et sont les sacs
restaurer sa cuisine qui va venir voir
un dollar ça va un peu se souvenir à ses
besoins elle serait un peu déjà un peu
sa survie j'ai peut-être une bonne
nouvelle pour vous ricardo non mais
j'avais madame bibeau a aujourd'hui
ottawa non 5 millions les banques
alimentaires mais on hamm est différente
organisons moisson j'ai parlé d' établi
des chefs
et puis elle fait son regard enfin tout
on est très ouvert à d'autres
partenaires pour distribuer de l'argent
alors savoir qu'en faire devant de ce
côté là aussi et jean françois
archambault qui est le fondateur de la
table ic et inter du solide
il m'a appelé hier à 9h30 c'est un go
quand tu as une idée dans la tête je dis
ça va arriver
alors lui est en contact pour aller
chercher un maximum mais je dois
souligner déjà la grande générosité de
plusieurs entreprises du québec
je pense à jean gattuso je pense aux
producteurs de porc je pensais seulement
qui donne les aliments qui seront
répartis dans nos cuisines et que nous
allons transformer pour pouvoir se
nourrir des gens qui vont en avoir bien
besoin
chez nous c'est drôle parce qu'en fait
ce pôle on avait préparé des milliers de
cocos de pâques
on savait pas quoi faire avec
jean-françois réussi à appeler les gens
de la dpj
on va donner plus de 4000 aux gens dans
les centres aux jeunes dans les centres
jeunesse
on est beaucoup en soirée il faut faire
quelque chose pour se prendre en main il
ya des gens qui sont vraiment démunis il
faut les aider mais en même temps qu'est
ce que ça vous si ça peut être très
gratifiant de contenant dix ans
d'efforts un grand effort de solidarité
comme celui là pour vous c'est tout ce
qui nous reste c'est tout ce qui nous
reste
on ne sait pas comment on va fonctionner
il ya des jeux 10 % des restaurants au
canada qui ont fait faillite
chaque jour qui passe nous faut vraiment
se refaire des scénarios pour dire
comment on va pouvoir repartir la
machine
comment on peut protéger les emplois
qu'on a créé nous c'est plus de 85% de
notre entreprise de nos nos employés qui
ont été mises à pied temporairement la
protection de ses entreprises la peau
que ces gens lui revient le plus tôt
possible pour savoir que c'est crève
coeur les gens à qui on a dû dire vous
dire allez au chômage chez des gens
compétents
pierre thion qui ont des valeurs qui ont
envie de le faire est dû aux
circonstances son prix chez ea a regardé
la situation pensais déjà que c'est un
métier difficile où je pense qu'elle a
la marge est pas si extraordinaire que
ça ce n'est conscient quand tout va bien
4 5% quand tout va bien ayant tous vos
billets quand tout va bien
qu'est ce que vous pensez qu'il va
ressortir de ne serait-ce que de votre
expérience à vous la tablée des chefs
plus d'une semaine des as puis dans le
monde
la restauration a pas parce que
maintenant les lits ont pu servir pour
emporter donc les gens c'est détruire
leur survie un peu comme si on pense que
ça va prendre des mois et des mois avec
les gens est vraiment pleinement
confiance retourner dans les restaurants
mais on peut parler du désastre
économique et de tout ce qui peut nous
arriver encore dans les semaines et les
mois à venir
par contre tous on est conscient du
seces de wingles de solidarité les gens
cuisinent ces six milliards qu'ils
étaient qui était disons donné dans la
restauration qui sont qui est transférée
vers les marchés les supermarchés mais
jean cuisine
j'ai fait une vidéo sur le père
récemment c'est plus deux millions de
personnes qui l'ont vu et qui tout à
coup se met à faire du pain des gens qui
n'avaient pas confiance en eux et le
sont
avec les enfants ou juste e en couple ou
seuls dix bons jeux mais c'est et
réalisation beaucoup plus de talent qui
croyait chine assc avec la table et ont
fait depuis 20 ans dire aux jeunes vous
êtes extraordinaire vous avez de grands
potentiels
il faut juste l'essayer mais il y
beaucoup de zulte a cependant qui
réalise qu finalement chevaux et d'un
fils ma famille est heureuse
ma femme est heureuse mon mari il ya
quelque chose qui j'espère vont rester
c'est fédérateur sa jeune et a beaucoup
merci beaucoup j'ai bien joué mais je
voudrais vous faire un comptage et merci